on est autour d'une table en parle des
mots de liberté des mots passeport pour
le juriste ça ça a des conséquences
extrêmement graves
ces mots-là ces mots que vous employez
on donnerait les employés à genoux
attention parce que quand on prend
l'habitude de parler de nos libertés
comme ça mais c'est le jour où vous les
aurez plus allez demander aux chinois
allez demander aux coréens si ces
problèmes se posent pas tant qu
effectivement nouvelle zélande
excusez moi il nous était d'aider des
leçons avec des mots que j'ai fait un
discours du juriste qui n'a pas de sens
mais monsieur ouvrez les yeux sur le nom
rationner attendez on passe à fait ça
fait un an que tout le monde est dans la
merde à cause d'un ambitieux vous
laisser dire on ne met pas dans la merde
à cause des russes de la mer à cause
d'une politique au stade y répondait à m
division alors je vous dis une chose je
ne comprends pas votre discours qui ça
sert certainement très juste moi je suis
approximatif et moi j'ouvre les yeux
moi je veux qu'ils crèvent des habits
axima ce jour quelqu'un qui tombe bien
j'adore 10 on attendait des buteurs il
est alors elle était axée remet tout on
est fermé il ya plus que dire sinon il
se sent seul monsieur ça s'appelle du
katanga cdu/csu monsieur s'appelle du
pathos et s'est pas fait ça on fait ça
ainsi maintenant c'est du pathos départ
du mandat quel sens et une pertinence
parce que si vous vous engagez sur le
terrain de l'airbus
est-ce que tu as qu'effectivement ça
mérite un débat la scène d'où le fait on
a je vous rappelle effectivement
attendez attendez le cyclo monsieur vous
nous avez laissé parler les gens vous
avez raison de souligner que j'attaque
oxydatif
alors je suis d'accord vous êtes
approximately totalement simplement
effectivement ce qui me dérange c'est
que vous dites je suis proxim hâtif et
j'ouvre les yeux sans nous rendre compte
de la contradiction en soit je ne fais
pas ma tite ouvert les yeux à la tête
que si vous les témoins coccyx matif
vous pourriez ouvrir les yeux sur les
armes de l'homme sur une réalité
monsieur c'est que nous parlons d'un
virus au taux de létalité encore
relativement faible et sur lequel on a
le droit de grève en garde les
commerçants mais monsieur ces fous de
dieu dit ressasser les vieux létalité
est très bien ce bateau qui peut nous
éclairer là dessus moi je vraiment ce
que vous dites vous avez raison parce
que nous on le vit à l'hôpital
maintenant nous on le vit à l'hôpital m
je dois vous dire quand même ce que ce
que nous nous vivons contraire nie pas
que c'est jeudi pour vous avez quand
vous avez 80 mille morts moi je veux pas
rentrer dans le débat il ya une tribune
de monsieur le bayer dans le monde en
lisant ça ne compte c'est une espérance
de vie non chaque vie compte la norme et
non mais laissez les deux minutes en
omettre la la je parle je pars entendu
et c'est peut-être d'un côté le côté
humaniste je rentre pas dans le domaine
juridique
il ya 80 mille morts si j'étais persuadé
si j'étais vraiment persuadé qu'on
arrivait à régler le problème avec un
passeport avec un certificat matinale je
vous dirais ok on y va lexie ont réglé
le problème économique
je ne pense pas mais moi je pense que
effectivement pendant quelque temps on
doit vivre il faut attendre
effectivement qu'on arrive à vacciner le
maximum de population il faudra faire
attention variant il faudra voir comment
va adapter le vaccin y aura certainement
des rappels et tous mes jeux il nous
reste un semblant de liberté encore et
je veux pas l'altérer je ne veux pas
altéré ce semblant de liberté et je ne
pense pas que la solution si vous voulez
ce soit effectivement un certificat
parce que ça va ça va ouvrir du jour au
lendemain il ya d'autres maladies vous
avait dit moi je pense comme
infectiologues à la tuberculose à
d'autres maladies si vous mettez si on
met le doigt
si on met le doigt là dedans on en
surplus il n'y a aucune il y aura aucune
limite
donc il faut être patient il faut être
patient il y aura des obligations qui ne
seront dictés par les autres pays et
puis il faut il faut élargir la france
parce que malheureusement je veux dire
quand c'est une pandémie pandémie ça
veut dire que le monde entier touchés